meanwhile the democrats just keep saying
awful things about republicans because
this is the way that it works guys
don't you understand it's time for unity
by which they mean surrender
it's time for you and they don't just
mean surrender in the election 2020.
right the the
electoral college is already voted they
mean surrender forever right surrender
your priorities
just let the democrats have their way
with the country that is what they mean
and so barack obama captain unity right
he's doing his book tour
he's he's such a unifying figure
remember according to the media this guy
was
the most unifying figure in modern
american politics he really just brought
people together that's all barack obama
did he was unbelievably divisive
and the rise of the intersectional
coalition the rise of intersectionality
is a philosophy
it really occurred under his watch and
it was a political move by obama
that he really started to treat separate
segments of the american population as
voting blocks that he could appeal to
and then cobble together a coalition
against the quote unquote system
that really did break apart the i think
that that if the country
is is irrevocably broken a lot of people
on the left are going to attribute that
to election 2016.
no way no way the country got broken in
2012. that's when the country got broken
in 2008 barack obama ran as a
traditional unifying political figure
right no red states no blue states the
united states by 2012 he had basically
decided that he was going to abandon
pushing a message that was acceptable
and palatable and interesting for a
majority of americans he was instead
going to go to each intersectional group
tell them he's going to prioritize their
needs cobble them together and then
direct them at the overarching system
and suggest that if you disagreed with
him it was because you're bigoted
against those specific groups
if somebody broke american politics it
was this schmuck anyway here's the
shmuck
saying that the gop is the minority
party and then saying that the senate
basically shouldn't exist anymore so
that's exciting
he attacks the senate and the electoral
college but
don't worry unity is on its way guys the
era of good feelings is here
the republican party is the minority
party in this country
the only reason that it doesn't look
like they're the minority party is
because of
structures like the u.s senate
and the electoral college that don't
render them the majority party
so so they have certain built-in
advantages
around power given their population
distribution and how
our government works but the truth of
the matter is is that 60
of the people are are occupying what i
would consider a more
reality-based uh
universe okay by the way isn't this
hilarious stuff he's saying that to
trevor noah on comedy central
i mean that's comedying right there and
trevor noah just sitting there hey so
here is your very serious democratic
party joe biden being interviewed by
stephen colbert
and barack obama being interviewed by
trevor noah slow clap for the
anti-entertainment crew
the very serious political crew how did
they get trump i can't imagine i can by
the way
he happens to be wrong about this when
he says that the democrats are the
majority party
he is right on a federal level right now
in terms of the house and in terms of
the presidential vote
he is certainly wrong on the state level
on the state level
right now the the state level chambers
republicans control about 3 900 seats
in state legislative houses and the
democrats control about 3 400 seats in
state legislative houses
okay when it comes to state senate
republicans control 32 state senates
democrats control 18. okay so
no that is not correct okay it turns out
we do have a series
the reason he hates the senate of course
is because he dislikes the fact that
there are institutional obstacles to
cramming down
his pure mob rule majoritarian ideas on
everybody else
that's really what he wants to do and
then people wonder why why republicans
and conservatives feel threatened
we understand that you guys want to get
rid of all the military institutions
that preserve individual rights
we get it we understand that you just
want a bare majority to force
itself on the bare minority that you
don't want any of those rights protected
so long as the
as long as the communal interests cut
the other way
and and it's not just obama obviously
it's people like
this biden inaugural official so there's
a biden inaugural official named
stephanie cutter right she was also
a a member of the team hillary
instead and a member of the obama team
as well and so stephanie cutter
tweeted out in the wake of the
statement by jen o'malley dylan who is
one of biden's deputy chiefs of staff
she suggested that republicans were
efforts right so now stephanie cutter
who was a longtime senior advisor to
barack obama said quote this story is
based on one anonymous donor really
and does anyone really disagree with the
sentiment this is because axios ran a
piece
saying that some biden aides were
worried that o'malley dillon had called
the gop efforts
so stephanie carter said the story is
based on one anonymous donor really does
anyone really disagree with the
sentiment
jen just had the guts to say it will
republicans prove it wrong doubt
it okay well so in other words she's
right
right so you have top obama official and
a top biden official both saying
that republicans are efforts but don't
worry guys it's time for unity it's time
to get together why won't republicans
just give it up why won't republicans
just you know sit down and shut up
meanwhile you have msnbc host maddie
hassan suggesting that donald trump
should be overtly prosecuted for covid
deaths
yes the era of good feelings is here
guys there will be no recriminations
it's not going to be about punishing the
other side it's not it's not about
viciousness or cruelty
it is simply about you know bringing
back a time of unity and and
togetherness that that's that's why
we're now calling for the prosecution of
the sitting presidents of the united
states for the effects of a global
pandemic that have killed millions of
people all over the planet
donald trump killed hundreds of
thousands of people who presided over
the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of people
preventable death here at home
in the united states of america and that
for me you know you talk about morally
abominable it's sociopathic
and i think people should be held to
account i think they should be
prosecuted
the people behind these preventable
deaths should be prosecuted when they
leave office on january 20th
so this is this is where things stand in
our culture right now is that people
must be punished people must be punished
charles blow has another terrible column
in the new york times i mean it's
another week so of course he has another
terrible terrible column
saying just the same thing right he says
joe biden as he has always said is
seeking to be a unifying president to be
the president of the people who didn't
vote for him
as well as the ones who did i want to
have that same optimistic spirit but
i admit my attempts at it may falter i
don't want to be the person who holds a
grudge
but i also don't want to be the person
who ignores a lesson the act of
remembering that so many americans were
willing to continue the harm to me and
others into the country itself
isn't spiteful but wise so in other
words
remember that so many people voted for
trump they are the enemy
they are the enemy anybody who voted for
trump is the enemy
meanwhile you got kareem abdul-jabbar
openly suggesting
that we have to go after hollywood stars
who do not go along with the prevailing
of political norms
right here's how it feels to be for
those who are not conservative listen to
the show understand how it feels to be a
conservative in america
okay and facts don't care about your
feelings but the facts happen to back up
these particular feelings
okay there is a tsunami of institutional
hatred
against people who think differently
than the left the left is in control of
the scientific establishment the left is
in control of the university
establishment they're in control of the
media establishment they're in control
of the entertainment establishment
they're in control of the sports
establishment they're in control
of the of of the government
establishment as well particularly in
the
in the administrative state it feels as
though everywhere you turn there are
people who are sneering at you
now there are people on the hardcore
left say good that's the way it should
be but
if you are a good-hearted liberal and
you wish to have open conversations with
people
what you're gonna have to decide is
whether you wish to make common clause
with the sneerers
or whether you wish to make common cause
with people who still believe in
individual rights because here's the
thing
there's a high correlation between the
people who sneer at people who think
differently
and the people who wish to shut those
people down and violate individual
rights in the process
and kareem abdul-jabbar has a piece in
the hollywood reporter i mean it's a
perfect confluence of celebrity
saying that celebrities deserve a legacy
killing backlash
when they spread ignorance he says the
only thing people enjoy more than
watching a celebrities rocketing ascent
to international fame
is watching and aging celebrities
flaming plummet to the hard cold ground
of disgrace and obscurity
it is both a warning against hubris
believing you're too famous to fall and
a reminder that the same people who made
you popular
can turn on you some like bill cosby and
harvey weinstein committed heinous acts
to obliterate their achievements
but social media has provided a weapon
for others to commit instantaneous
career suicide and destroy any good
faith legacy they spent a lifetime
building
like howard hughes whose contributions
to aviation and filmmaking were
overshadowed by such
eccentricities as collecting his own
nail clippings in jars
these figures are obscuring their own
careers
so he talks about rudy giuliani and then
he talks about jk rowling
right jk rowling is super bad terrible
terrible terrible because jk rowling
says that boys and girls exist
says kareem abdul-jabbar she deserves
the hatred he says her anti-trans tweets
may not only damage the harry potter and
fantastic beasts franchises they could
have changing her entire
literary legacy even the stars of the
movies
daniel radcliffe emma watson rubert
grint eddie redmayne have spoken out
against her position well you know if
eddie redmayne says the thing
well then hold the fort
john cleese's tone deaf defensive
rallying left many fans bitterly
disappointed tarnishing his reputation
and then he goes after jon voight and
then he goes after roseanne barr
he goes after basically anybody who
disagrees with him he says many imbue
many americans imbue stars with
political and social intelligence they
just don't have
great success in one field can lead to
the delusion that all your thoughts are
great
says the former basketball center who is
now writing in the hollywood reporter
about politics
yes yes it can can't it it does it's
true
there are a lot of people who think that
because they're famous they know things
and then interesting
kareem abdul-jabbar the irresponsibility
of tweeting irrational and harmful
opinions to millions regardless of the
damaging consequences to their country
or people's lives proves these stars
deserve the harsh backlash again
we are back in the mode of all that
matters here
is the is the effect that it has on
leftist feelings that's all that matters
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content